[Music]  hey Victor yeah I'm gonna be everything  I want to be please see oh the world has  a dream that dreams are not reality if  you escape with me tonight my dreams  will come true do you have a plan a  brilliant plan  I call them chicken wing shins  don't fly good morning sunshine  you when's the last time you brushed  your teeth will become the greatest  dancer and I will become the greatest  inventor ever  [Music]  I'm the caretaker you can stay with me  until you've got on your feet starting  tomorrow we'll have an audition to mind  you ballet can you dance I think I can  adil training starts at 5:00 a.m.  tomorrow 5:00 a.m.  do you Thea was stupid to come to Paris  don't say that we should never give up  on our dreams so how do I get that part  you get the part of Sebastian  tonight was a good performance  hey everyone will travel like this  right  [Music]  are you doing uh nothing I'm stretching  oh yeah yeah oh no here we go  since I can remember I've wanted to do  [Music]